Transcriptor: Anna Sobota
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En febrero pasado,
dos semanas antes de que Costa Rica
entrara en cuarentena por coronavirus,
me diagnosticaron depresión posparto.
Más o menos cinco meses después
del nacimiento de mi segunda hija.
Y para mi sorpresa, no era la primera vez
que me enfrentaba a esta enfermedad.
Ya había pasado por ella
con mi primer hijo.
Me aceleré por el trabajo,
por la casa, por la familia.
No me di cuenta de que mi ser
y mi matrimonio
colapsaban frente a mis ojos.
Después del diagnóstico,
el mundo entero se encerró.
Y así lo tenía que hacer yo
con mi angustia, con mi tristeza,
con mi desesperanza, con mis preguntas,
con mi dolor y, por supuesto,
con mi esposo y mis dos hijos.
Me sentía como una muerta.
Tenía una sensación como si
una tela me rodease el pecho
y me estirase muy fuerte hacia abajo.
Era como un vacío.
Además, tenía un odioso acompañante,
un fantasma en mi cabeza,
que me asustaba continuamente.
Me preguntaba:
¿Toda mi vida iba a vivir así?
Comencé mi proceso buscando
más información sobre esta enfermedad
y me di cuenta de que cada vez hay
más información técnica
sobre la relevancia y la complejidad
de los problemas de salud mental.
Sin embargo, hay muy pocas personas
que se atreven a hablar abiertamente
de estas enfermedades.
Para que se hagan una idea:
en el 2030, como sociedad,
la depresión nos va a costar más.
Los problemas de salud mental nos van
a costar más de lo que nos cuesta
el cáncer, la diabetes
y los problemas respiratorios juntos.
Una de cada cinco mujeres de países
en desarrollo sufre de depresión posparto.
Esto es un problema real.
Como pueden ver la ciencia,
los investigadores
están haciendo su trabajo.
Pero, ¿estamos nosotros
como sociedad haciendo el nuestro?
Tenemos que comenzar a hablar y entender
más sobre los problemas de salud mental.
Pero más allá de esto, debemos ponerle
una cara más humana a estas enfermedades.
Y es por eso que hoy estoy aquí
contándoles mi historia.
En esa terapia en la que la psicóloga
me da el diagnóstico,
también me da la solución.
Me dice: “Gaby, todas enfermedades
en nuestra vida sólo vienen a activarnos
nuestro código curativo.
Ese código curativo está dentro de vos”.
Así que yo, muy juiciosa,
me dispuse a encontrar ese código.
Para aceptar y vivir con una depresión
posparto tenía que entenderla.
Junto con mi terapeuta descubrí
que la depresión tiene tres pilares.
El primero es la rabia.
Mi esposo podría contarles
un poquito más al respecto.
El segundo es la desesperanza.
Y el tercero, que para mí fue clave
y revelador, es la falta de la vitalidad.
La depresión no es tristeza,
como me lo habían enseñado.
La depresión es falta de la vitalidad.
En mi caso, era falta de la vitalidad.
Como madres, como mujeres, debemos
dejar de ver la depresión posparto
como nuestro primer gran fracaso.
La depresión posparto es una
condición y una enfermedad.
Nuestra única responsabilidad
es cómo la vamos a afrontar.
En ese proceso,
enfrentándome a mi enfermedad,
fui descubriendo distintas herramientas.
A mí me gusta llamarlas de amor propio.
Me ayudaban a navegar esas olas muy
bajas que trae consigo esta enfermedad.
Son cinco herramientas.
Primera es la decisión
de cómo queremos vivir el proceso.
Sí, podemos decidir cómo
queremos vivir el proceso.
La depresión no viene
a que nos resignemos.
La depresión viene a conectarnos
con lo que es importante para nosotras
y lo que hemos dejado de lado.
Aunque no fue fácil,
decidí convertir mi depresión
en un acto creativo,
en una oportunidad para
crear nuevas realidades.
Hay una frase que me llega al alma
y que dice:
“Una debe perder la vida
para volverla a encontrar”.
Y eso fue la depresión posparto
en ambas ocasiones en mi vida.
Fue ese cable a tierra que
me obligó a detenerme,
a hacer una pausa, y a entender,
y a crear esa nueva realidad
que yo deseaba ver en mi vida.
La segunda herramienta, y les confieso
que me cuesta muchísimo aplicarla,
es renunciar a la falsa ilusión
de que puedo controlarlo todo.
Y esto, automáticamente,
me conectó con mi espiritualidad.
Piensen en esas dos células que se unieron
para formar todo un nuevo ser.
¿Quién controló eso?
No fui yo.
¿Quién controla al día?
¿Quién controla la noche?
¿Quién controla el perfecto balance
que vemos en el universo?
Acababa de sentir la vida
dentro de mi vientre
y ahora, me tocaba abrir mi corazón
y ceder el control
para que ese movimiento,
para que esa vida llegara dentro de mí,
para que ese milagro sucediera en mí
porque yo estaba como una muerta.
En el universo, en la naturaleza,
todo se mueve hacia la sanación,
hacia el balance.
Pero debemos de ceder el control
para que ese movimiento
suceda de manera natural
en nuestras vidas.
En ese soltar y dejar fluir,
encontré mi tercera herramienta,
que es la respiración.
La depresión y la ansiedad
son dos enfermedades
que están completamente ligadas.
Mi primer síntoma de depresión posparto
fue un ataque de ansiedad.
En una noche de diciembre,
más o menos tres meses después de
que mi segunda hija nació,
ese ataque me tumbó al piso.
Mis manos me sudaban, mi corazón estaba
muy acelerado, yo no podía respirar.
Tenía ese fantasma
asustándome en mi cabeza.
Tenía mucho, mucho, mucho miedo.
Por suerte, ahí estaba mi hermano,
que innumerables veces en su vida
ha tenido que pasar
por este tipo de ataques.
Y él me decía: “Gaby, respira, a ver,
mírame a los ojos. Respira conmigo.
Respira. Eso que tienes
en tu cabeza no está pasando.
Respira conmigo,
respira conmigo, respira”.
Me desvanecía en sus brazos
y él me abrazaba muy fuerte.
Éste fue el primero de
muchísimos ataques de ansiedad.
Algunos de los cuales,
logré evitar con respiración.
Otros los tuve que pasar.
Y fue la respiración
que me ayudó a sobreponerme.
Y bueno, en ese respirar consciente
comencé a habitar mi cuerpo de nuevo,
a darme cuenta que estaba viva.
Y aquí viene mi cuarta herramienta,
que personalmente me apasiona,
y es la de volver
a habitar nuestro cuerpo.
¡Y qué gran reto!
Somos un sistema:
nuestra mente, nuestras emociones,
nuestro cuerpo, todo está ligado.
Así que podríamos decir que cualquier
enfermedad en nuestra vida,
puede ser el resultado
de un fallo en ese sistema.
Así que buscaba abordar mi depresión
de una manera sistemática,
viéndome como un todo.
Como muchos saben el embarazo,
el parto, los hijos
nos revolucionan el cuerpo.
Volver a habitarlo
y a identificarnos con él,
a veces, nos cuesta mucho.
Pero nuestro cuerpo es poderoso,
acaba de dar la vida.
No podemos ignorarlo.
Pero bueno, ¿cómo comencé
a habitar mi cuerpo de nuevo?
Lo hice a partir de la alimentación
y el movimiento.
Para que lo entiendan: la alimentación
es esa energía que entra
y el movimiento
es esa energía que sale.
Comer sano y delicioso es posible.
Es la mejor manera que tenemos
para consentir a nuestro poderoso cuerpo.
Mi alimentación, personalmente,
la enfoqué en fortalecer mi intestino,
ya que cada vez hay
más evidencias científicas
de la existencia de una relación,
y una comunicación,
entre nuestro intestino y nuestro cerebro.
Así que, quería fortalecer mi intestino
para fortalecer mi mente.
Y en cuanto al movimiento,
no pasé muchas horas en el gimnasio.
Primero, porque no me gusta el gimnasio.
Segundo, porque, evidentemente,
no tenía mucho tiempo.
Pero busqué una forma para que mi cuerpo
se expresara, un espacio para mí.
Y ese espacio lo encontré en el yoga.
Pero puede ser bailar, patinar,
jugar al tenis,
lo que sea que te haya hecho
o te haga feliz.
Al final, el movimiento y la alimentación
son para recordarnos ese placer
que se siente al estar vivas.
Y bueno, mi última herramienta,
que fue mi as bajo la manga,
es mi red de apoyo.
Mi esposo que, valientemente, me acompañó
en este proceso, estuvo siempre a mi lado.
Aunque quizás tenía más miedo que yo.
Mis amigas, mi comunidad de yoga,
mi familia.
Pero eso sí, esta red de apoyo
solo se activó el día en que yo me acerqué
y les conté el doloroso proceso
que estaba viviendo.
Ahí estuvieron para mí,
y ahí siguen para mí.
Y bueno, más allá de estas herramientas
hermosas que nos invitan a actuar,
debo confesarles que también
encontré el valor de no actuar,
de desconectarme para volver a conectar,
de sumergirme inmóvil en la naturaleza
para conectar con ese balance de sanación
que tiene la naturaleza.
Madres, mujeres:
necesitamos un descanso, una pausa.
Un respiro prolongado.
Nos lo merecemos.
Cada depresión posparto es distinta.
Cada persona es distinta.
Pero yo estoy aquí, frente a Uds.,
compartiéndoles mi proceso
para que esas personas que están por ahí
sufriendo una depresión posparto,
cuenten con herramientas más humanas
para navegar estas olas tan bajas
que trae consigo la depresión.
Pero más allá de eso,
que sepan que la depresión se acaba,
tiene un fin.
A mí, la depresión posparto
me cambió la vida,
me hizo más humana.
Me dio permiso para pedir ayuda,
para ceder el control,
para sentir dolor y falta de vitalidad.
Pero más allá de esto,
la depresión posparto vino a recordarme
que estoy viva y que eso,
vale la pena celebrarlo.
Muchas gracias.